[Music]
Who here's building agents?
Who here's your hand up if you built
like 10 plus agents? Anyone here built
like a hundred agents?
All right, we got a few. Awesome. Love
it. Um, so I think a lot of us have been
on this journey of building agents. Um,
and what happened with me was, you know,
I decided I want to build an agent. We
figured out what we wanted it to do. Uh,
we want to move fast. We're developers,
so we use libraries. We don't write
everything from scratch. Um, and you get
it to like 70 80%. It's enough to get
the CEO excited and get six more people
added to your team. But then you kind of
realize that 70 80% isn't quite good
enough. And that if you want to get past
that 70 80% quality bar, you're seven
layers deep in a call stack trying to
reverse engineer how does this prompt
get built or how do these tools get
passed in? Where does this all come
from? Uh and if you're like me, you
eventually just throw it all away and
start from scratch. Um or you may even
find out that this is not a good problem
for agents. I remember one of the first
agents that I tried to build was uh a
DevOps agent. I was like, "Here's my
make file. You can run make commands. Go
build the project." Couldn't figure it
out. Did all the things in the wrong
order. I'm like, "Cool, let's fix the
prompt." And I over the la next two
hours I'm more and more detail about
what everything was and every single
step and the exact until I got to the
point where I was like this is the exact
order to run the build steps. It was a
cool exercise but at the end of it I was
like you know I could have written the
bash script to do this in about 90
seconds. Not every problem needs an
agent. Um and so I've been on this
journey. I think a lot of you have been
on similar journeys. Um and what
happened was is I went and talked um in
trying to help people build better, more
reliable agents. I talked to a 100 plus
founders, builders, engineers. Um, and I
started to notice patterns. One was that
most production agents weren't that
agentic at all. They were mostly just
software, but that there were these core
things that a lot of people were doing.
There were these patterns that were
making their LLM based apps really,
really good. Um, and none of them were
doing kind of a green field rewrite.
Rather, they were taking these small
modular concepts that didn't have names
and didn't have definitions and they
were applying them to their existing
code. Um, and what's really cool about
this is I don't think you need an AI
background to do this. This is software
engineering 101. Well, probably not 101,
but just like Heroku needed to define
what it meant to build cloud. We didn't
even call them cloud native back then,
but this was how you built applications
that could run in the cloud 10 years
ago. Um, I decided to put together what
I thought would be the 12 factors of AI
agents. Um, from everything that I've
seen working in the field. Um, so we put
up this GitHub repo. You can go read it.
Um, turns out a lot of other people
agreed and felt the same thing. Um, so
we were on the front page of Hacker News
all day, 200k impressions on social. Uh,
I'm just going to put this one up and no
comment.
Um, and just for context, we got to like
4,000 stars in like a month or two. Uh,
there's 14 active contributors. Um, it's
very easy to read that thing and and
hear the talk and say like, oh, we're
here, this is the anti-framework talk. I
am not here to bash frameworks. I would
think of this as much as anything as a
wish list, a a list of feature requests
is how can we make frameworks serve the
needs of really good builders who need a
really high reliability and want to move
fast still. Um, so what am I here to do?
Uh, I want you to kind of forget
everything you know about agents and
kind of rethink from first principles
how we can apply everything we've
learned from software engineering to the
practice of building really reliable
agents. Um, so we're going to mix the
order up a little bit. If you want all
12 factors in order, that's a 30-minute
talk, so we're going to bundle some
stuff together. There will be a QR code
at the end. You can go dig through it at
your leisure. Um, factor one, the most
magical things that LMS can do. Has
nothing to do with loops or switch
statements or code or tools or anything.
It is turning a sentence like this into
JSON that looks like this. Doesn't even
matter what you do with that JSON. Uh,
those are what the other factors are
for. But if you're doing that, that's
one piece that you can bring into your
app today. Um, factor four. This leads
right to uh did anyone read this paper
uh go to considered harmful or maybe
just heard about it? I never actually
read it. Uh but it was all about we had
this abstraction in the C programming
language and a bunch of other
programming languages at the time that
said this thing go to it makes code
terrible. It's the wrong abstraction. It
no one should use it. I'm going to go
ahead and go on a limb here and say tool
use is harmful. And I put it in quotes
because I'm not talking about giving an
agent access to the world. Obviously
that's super badass. But what I think is
making things hard is the idea that tool
use is this magical thing where this
ethereal alien entity is interacting
with its environment because what is
happening is our LM is putting out JSON.
We're going to give that to some
deterministic code that's going to do
something and then maybe we'll feed it
back. But again, those are other
factors. So if you have structures like
this and you can get the LLM to output
something that generates them, then you
can pass it into a loop like this or a
switch statement like this. There's
nothing special about tools. It's just
JSON and code. Uh, that's factor four.
Factor eight, and these are we're going
to do a couple kind of bundled together
here. Owning your control flow. Um, and
I want to take a step back and kind of
talk about how we got here. Um, we've
been writing DAGs in software for a long
time. If you've written an if statement,
you've written a directed graph. Uh,
code is a graph. You may also be
familiar with DAG orchestra. Anyone ever
use like Airflow or Prefect or any of
these things? Um, so like this kind of
concept of breaking things up into nodes
gives you certain reliability
guarantees. But what agents were
supposed to do, and I think a lot of
people talk about this, and I think in
some cases this is realized, is you
don't have to write the deck. You just
tell the LM, here's the goal, and LM
will find its way there. And we model
this as a really simple loop. You know,
LM is determining the next step. You're
building up some context window until
the LM says, "Hey, we're done."
Um, so what this looks like kind of in
practice is, you know, you have an event
come in. You pass it into your prompt.
Uh, it says you want to call an API and
you get your result. Put that on the
context window. Pass the whole thing
back into the prompt. This is like the
most naive simple way of building
agents. And the LM's going to call a
couple steps and then eventually it's
going to say, cool, we've done all the
tasks from the initial event, which
maybe was a user message asking it to do
something. Maybe it's an outage. Um, but
then we get our final answer. And our
materialized DAG is just these three
steps in order. Um,
turns out this doesn't really work. Uh,
especially when you get to longer
workflows. Mostly it's long context
windows. There's other reasons you could
poke at as well. Um, and people say,
"Oh, like even as anyone put like two
million tokens into Gemini before and
like try to see what happens." Like you
can do it. You'll get an answer. The API
will return you something. But I don't
think anyone will argue with you that
you will always get like tighter,
better, higher reliability results by
controlling and limiting the number of
tokens you put in that context window.
Um, so it doesn't quite work, but we're
going to use that as our abstraction to
build on. What's an agent really? You
have your prompt, which gives
instructions about how to select the
next step. You have your switch
statement, which takes whatever the
model output JSON, uh, and does
something with it. You have a way of
building up your context window. And
then you have a loop uh that determines
when and where and how and why you exit.
Um and if you own your control flow, you
can do fun things like break and switch
and summarize and LM is judge and all
this stuff. Um and this leads right into
kind of how we manage execution state
and business state of our agents. Um a
lot of tools will give you things like
current step, next step, retry counts,
all these like DAG orchestrators, they
all have this kind of concepts in them.
Um but you also have your business
state. What are the messages that have
happened? What data are we displaying to
the user? What things are we waiting on
approval for? Um, and we want to be able
to launch, pause, resume these things
like we do for any standard APIs. Um,
this is all just software. And so if you
can put your agent behind a REST API or
an MCP server, um, and manage that loop
in such a way that normal request comes
in and we load that context window to
the LLM. Um, we're going to allow our
agent to call longunning tool. So we can
interrupt the workflow, serialize that
context window straight into a database
because we own the context window. We'll
get into that. Um, and then when we
launch the workflow, um, eventually it's
going to call back with that state ID
and the result. We use the state ID to
load the state back out of the database,
and then we can append the result to the
program and then send it right back into
the LM. The agent doesn't even know that
things happened in the background. Um,
agents are just software, so let's build
software. Um, and building really good
ones need requires a lot of flexibility.
And so you really want to own that inner
loop of of how all that stuff is fitting
together. Um, that's unifying. That's
pause and resume. Uh factor two, this
one is I think most people find first is
like you really want to own your
prompts. There's some good extractions
that if you don't want to spend a lot of
time handwriting a prompt, you can put
stuff in and you'll get out um a really
good set of primitives um and a really
good prompt. Like this will make you a
banger prompt that like you would have
to go to prompt school for like three
months to build a prompt this good, but
eventually if you want to get past some
quality bar, you're going to end up
writing every single token by hand. Um
because LM are pure focus functions and
the only thing that determines the
reliability of your agent is how good of
tokens can you get out and the only way
the only thing that determines the
tokens you get out other than like
retraining your own model and something
like that is being really careful about
what tokens you put in.
Um I don't know what's better. I don't
know how you want to build your prompt,
but I know the more things you can try
and the more knobs you can test and the
more things you can evaluate, the more
likely you are to find something really
really good. Um owning your prompts, you
also want to own how you build your
context window. Um, so you can do the
standard open II messages format or in
this moment where you're telling the LLM
pick the next step, your only job is to
tell it what's happened so far. You can
put all that information however you
want into a single user message and ask,
hey, what's happening next or put in the
system message. So you can model your
event state, your thread model however
you want, um, and stringify it however
you want. And some of the traces that we
use in some of the agents we build
internally, I'll get into that in a sec,
um, might look like this. Um, but if
you're not looking at every single token
and if you're not optimizing the density
and the clarity of the way that you're
passing information to an LLM, you might
be missing out on upside and quality. So
LMS are pure functions, token in, tokens
out, and everything everything in making
agents good is context engineering. So
you have your prompt, you have your
memory, you have your rag, you have your
history. It's all just how do we get the
right tokens into the model. So it gives
us a really good answer and solves the
user's problem. solves my problem
mostly. Um, I don't know what's better,
but I know you want to try everything.
Um, so let's own your context building.
Um, this one's a little controversial.
Uh, that's why it's a it's a standalone
factor. And the way you make it good is
by integrating it with other factors.
But you could, um, when the model screws
up and it calls an API wrong or it calls
an API that's down, um, you could take
the tool call that it made and grab the
error that was associated with it, put
that on the context window, and have it
try again. Anyone ever had a bad time
with this? Seen like this thing just
like kind of spin out and like go crazy
and lose context and just get stuck. Um,
that's why you need to own your context
window. Don't just blindly put things
on. If you have errors and then you get
a valid tool call, clear all the air
pending errors out. Summarize them.
Don't put the whole stack trace on your
context. Figure out what you want to
tell the model so you get better
results. Um, contacting humans with
tools. This one's a little subtle. Um,
but I've seen this is just like what
I've seen in the wild. almost everybody
is like avoiding this very important
choice at the very beginning of output
where you're deciding between tool call
and message to the human. Um if you can
push that emphasis to a natural language
token, you can one give the model
different ways. You can be I'm done or I
need clarification or I need to talk to
a manager or whatever it is and two you
push the intent on that first token
generation and the sampling to something
that is natural language that the model
understands. Um, so your traces might
look like this if you're pulling in
human input here. Um, this lets you
build out auto outloop agents. I'm not
going to talk about this. If you go on
the site, there's a link to this this
post. I've written a lot about this. Um,
I don't know what's better, but you
should probably try everything. Um,
that's contacting humans with tools.
Goes right along with trigger things
from anywhere and meet users exactly
where they are. People don't want to
have seven tabs open of different chat
GPT style agents. Just let people email
with the agents you're building. Let
them slack with the agents you're
building. Discord, SMS, whatever it is.
We see this taking off all over the
place. Um, and you should have small
focused agents. So, we talked about this
structure and why it doesn't really
work. So, what does work? Um, the things
that people are doing that work really
well are micro agents. So, you still
have a mostly deterministic DAG and you
have these very small agent loops with
like three to 10 steps. We do this at
human layer. We have a bot that manages
our deployments. Most of our deploy
pipeline is deterministic CI/CD code.
But when we get to the point where the
GitHub PR is merged and the tests are
passing on development, excuse me, we
send it to a model. We say get this
thing deployed. Says cool, I'm going to
deploy the front end. Uh, and then you
can send that to a human. The human says
actually no, do the back end first. This
is taking natural language and turning
it into JSON. That is the next step in
our workflow. Um, backend gets proposed,
that gets approved, it gets deployed,
then the agent knows, okay, I have to go
back and deploy the front end. Once
that's all done and it's successful, we
go right back out into deterministic
code. So now we're going to run the end
to end test against prod. If it's done,
otherwise we hand it back to a little
roll back agent that is very similar on
the inside. Um I'm not going to go into
it, but here's it working in our Slack
channel. Um yeah, 100 tools, 20 steps,
easy. Um manageable context, clear
responsibilities. Um a lot of people
say, "What what if LM do keep getting
smarter? What if I can put two million
tokens in and it can do it?" Um, and I
think we very much will see something
like this where you start with a mostly
deterministic workflow and you start
sprinkling LMS into your code, into your
backend, into your logic. Over time, the
LMS are able to do bigger, more complex
tasks until this whole API endpoint or
pipeline or whatever it is is just run
by an agent. That's great. Uh, but you
still want to know how to engineer these
things to get the best quality. This is
someone from notebook LM and it's
basically their take and I think they
did this well is find something that is
right at the boundary of what the model
can do reliably like that it can't get
right all the time and if you can figure
out how to get it right reliably anyways
because you've engineered reliability
into your system then you will have
created something magical and you will
have created something that's better
than what everybody else is building. So
that's small focused agents. There's a
meme here about stateless reducers. I
guess someone actually tweeted at me,
it's not a reducer, it's a transducer
because there's multiple steps. Um, but
basically agents should be stateless.
You should own the state, manage it
however you want. Um, so we're all still
finding the right abstractions. Um,
there's a couple blog posts I link in
the paper. Um, frameworks versus
libraries. There's a really old one from
Ruby Comp about like do we want
duplication or is like do we want to try
to figure out these abstractions? Um, if
you want to make a 12-factor agent, we
are working on something called create
12-factor agent because I believe that
what agents need is not bootstrap. You
don't need a wrapper around an internal
thing. You need something more like shad
CN, which is like scaffolded out and
then I'll own it and I'll own the code
and I'm okay with that.
So, in summary, agents are software. You
all can build software. Anyone ever
written a switch statement before?
While loop. Yeah. Okay. So, we can do
this stuff. LM are stateless functions,
which means just make sure you put the
right things in the context and you'll
get the best results. Own your state and
your control flow and just do it and
just understand it because it's going to
give you flexibility. And then find the
bleeding edge. Find ways to do things
better than everybody else by really
curating what you put in the model and
how you control what comes out. Um, and
my tech agents are better with people.
Find ways to let agents collaborate with
humans. Um, there are hard things in
building agents, but you should probably
do them anyways, at least for now, and
you should do most of them. Um, I think
a lot of frameworks try to take away the
hard AI parts of the problem so that you
can just kind of drop it in and go. And,
uh, I think it should be the opposite. I
think the tools that we get should take
away the other hard parts so that we can
spend all our time focusing on the hard
AI parts, on getting the prompts right,
on getting the flow right, on getting
the tokens right. So the reason why I'm
here is like I do run a small business.
Um we have a startup where we try to
help you do a lot of what we do we do in
the open is open source and I think it's
really important and we need to work on
it together. There's some other things
that are hard but not that important and
not that interesting. So that's what
we're solving at human layer. Um working
on something called the A2 protocol.
Come find me if you want to talk about
this but this is a way to get like
consolidation around how agents can
contact humans. Um but mostly I just
love automating things. I've built tons
and tons of agents internally for my
personal stuff, for finding apartments,
for all kinds of internal business stuff
we do at human layer. Um, so thank you
all for watching. Let's go build
something. I'll see you in the hallway
track. Uh, I'd love to chat if you want
to riff on agents or building or control
flow or any of this stuff. That's
12actor agents.
[Applause]